what's going on realm it's lord addict
here this could be a different type of
review than i normally do for those of
you that know i review games on this
channel i i play a game to the
completion and i tell you exactly how i
feel about it
but there is one particular thing that i
generally have always stayed away from
and that is vr for those of you that's
been following the podcast for a while
you know
i'm not a fan of vr and it's because of
bad experiences with the vr but your boy
got his hands on a quest too
and an oculus quest to actually is the
official name and it's time that you
know the realm knows exactly how addict
feels about vr actually playing probably
one of if not the most popular brand of
vr that's on the market right now so
that's what this video is about i'm
going to be breaking down
the vr quest 2 with oculus quest 2 and
i'm going to tell you how i feel about
it so without any further ado if you
guys liked the video definitely hit that
like button definitely go ahead and
subscribe to the iron lords podcast
channel the chat you're watching us on
now we go live every sunday at 1 p.m 11
a.m on the football time
and without any further ado let's review
the oculus quest 2.
[Music]
what's going on round today we're going
to be reviewing the oculus quest 2. you
guys know how i've always been in the
past when it comes to any type of vr
product i'm not the biggest fan of vr in
general but i got my hands on an oculus
quest too and i figured you know this is
the perfect time to really give the
opportunity to the vr industry and see
exactly was i wrong was i not wrong is
this something that i should have been
looking into this entire time or was i
right the entire time and it's not
something that is for me first thing i
want to talk about really is i want to
talk about the actual comfort when it
comes to the oculus quest 2. so the
quest 2 has straps in the back that let
you tighten how tight it is around your
actual head and it's got one over the
top of your head that lets you tighten
how it fits around your whole head in
general and i honestly say that as far
as this system it works pretty well i'm
usually i'm a pretty big guy plus i have
glasses so it was letting me adjust it
to the way where it would fit my glasses
and it would fit where it doesn't feel
like it's too tight doesn't feel like
it's gonna slide off very easy i have
one of those things where if something's
too tight on me i tend to sweat a lot
and i noticed that when it wasn't
adjusted correctly i would sweat a lot
it would be a very bad experience and
for the most part if something like that
happens to you when you have the quest 2
on it's usually just something that you
have to readjust it's not the actual
quest to what that makes sense inside
the actual quest headset there is
clearly you know the the the lenses that
you look into the good thing about these
lenses it's got three settings so it's
got one two and three and how that
pretty much works is it works
simultaneously with the actual straps
that go around your head to make sure
that this is as comfortable as it needs
to be now keep in mind if you ever put
the oculus quest 2 on and it looks
blurry a little bit nine times out of
ten that setting that lens setting
inside the headset needs to be adjusted
a little bit i did notice that when i
first started playing it i didn't really
understand that and i was getting
headaches pretty frequently about every
45 minutes to an hour and i think that
really solved that fear that i had in
the past the only experiences i really
have with vr is that your pax's the e3s
they usually have a lot of vr boost
where you can actually try vr now i
would dabble in it a little bit but i
never really sat there and played like
every game that was on display but i
didn't try some of it and i got
headaches and i felt lightheaded almost
immediately kind of motion sickness i
did notice with the quest now i don't
know if it's with everything else but i
did notice with the quest it actually
had enough settings to where i could
adjust it and regardless how i would
feel at the beginning as long as i kept
adjusting that and trying to make it fit
me as a person as best as i could it
took away from that blurriness if i was
feeling like lightheaded nine times out
of ten it's because neither the straps
are too loose and the headset was too
loose so it was coming down a little bit
or the actual lenses inside wasn't at
the right caliber to actually combined
with the actual strap to make sure i had
a good experience with this vr headset
now let's talk about the actual
controllers for the quest too they look
pretty modern actually i didn't really
get that aspect where i felt like it was
made it was cheap it felt premium it
felt like when i held it it was white to
it i really enjoy situations like that
because there's nothing worse than
buying products that you feel like when
you drop it's gonna break and if you
even do drop it they got these little
straps kind of like the weave where you
know you could strap it on your arm and
even if you do drop this it's not going
to hit the ground so that's always a
nice safety feature that i've noticed a
lot of you know hand peripherals have
and i appreciate the oculus decided to
make sure it was on their controllers
now let's talk about the ui of the
oculus quest 2. it's a pretty decent ui
and i would say that it's very
responsive i was actually really
surprised by the responsiveness between
the controller and the actual quest
first thing that they ask you to do is
pretty much size up what type of room
you're in they want to know what the you
know how tall and how long the room is
and they want you to know like bend down
with the controller to figure out how
long it is between you and the floor so
they can really get a good estimate on
how big this room is that you're in and
it was pretty detailed i gotta admit
that you know one of the things that i
feel like vr is mistakenly has a concept
with is the fact that sometimes i feel
like you constantly have to be active to
play these games what i've realized when
i played the quest 2 is that's kind of
inaccurate you know you can actually
there is a stationary mode with the
quest 2 where you can sit in your chair
you can set it to where it's like look
i'm in this chair i want you to put the
circle diameter around you to where as
long as you're in that circle you're
going to be in the vr game or whatever
the ui that you're currently on as it is
now keep in mind that there is a room
scale one where you can draw like a
square around the room or how much room
you actually have because that was one
of the biggest fears i had in this i
don't have a whole lot of room for the
most part that is always the key factor
that made me not want to really be in
the vr because every time you see people
play the vr on social media or anything
like that on youtube it seemed like they
was all standard and i always felt like
i'mma break something i got too much
expensive stuff in this room to be in
pretty much an airport aisle you know
when you're in an airplane you're going
down those little tiny aisles that's
pretty much the the amount of room i
have in my room considering my desk my
tv's in here so i'm just like look i
don't think i have enough room but with
that stationary mode i can play pretty
much every game that i've came across
i'm sure there's games that you have to
be physically standing but every game
that i came across i was able to play
with that stationary mode and the cool
thing is they have these experimental
settings to where you can actually
physically put like like furniture in
there like chairs you know couches to
work you can actually sit down and if
you're in that room scale mode where you
actually draw a line in the room you're
in and that circle or that diameter that
you've drawn is the actual vr as long as
you're in that circle you're going to be
able to see the couch you're going to be
able to see the chair and you can sit
down pretty frequently you don't have to
like feel around like you're blind now
keep in mind if you do come out of the
little diameter that you've set up with
the room scaling or maybe you're in
stationary mode and you stand up it's
going to take you out of the vr and it's
going to give you this weird crispy not
crispy look but it's like a weird ghost
look on your room showing some type of
camera that's in front of the oculus i'm
not a big fan of this i always felt like
maybe they should have showed like an
actual there should be a camera in the
front that shows you what it's looking
like because sometimes you know you just
want to see what time it is or something
well there is a time in the actual
oculus but i always felt like if if i if
there should be a button that i can
press that i can just see what's going
on because if someone comes into my room
and i can sense that they're there i
have to like go through all these hoops
to actually see what's going on i can
just take the headset off but if you
take the headset off you actually like
pause the game kinda i don't know it's
kind of weird how that stuff work i do
feel like they need to be a little bit
better on settings like that to where
you know maybe you can press a button or
a hotkey or something where it
automatically goes to that ghostly look
to where you can see what's in your room
just in case if someone's in there that
shouldn't be in there maybe you have
like a child running around that you
gotta you know check where they're at i
feel like you know little things like
that it's me nitpicking but it is
something that i would like for them to
improve on now let's talk about
entertainment i feel like this is the
biggest thing vr is going to shine off
in the future and not necessarily
entertainment just you know that type of
scenery in general you know meetings at
work watching a movie
and you know just pretty much anything
you know play monopoly even to a point i
know that's more gaming wise but i feel
like the biggest thing that's going to
really capitalize this is just watching
movies with your friends watching you
know ufc fights with your friends
watching e3 with your friends i think
that they need to really space this out
and make sure that this is capitalized
on because i do think gaming is
important but i think they need to go
more on the social aspect when it comes
to vr because i feel like a lot of their
games is mainly focused on social
aspects so let's focus more on the
social aspect and then let's get those
social people going in there you know to
watch movies or you know watch ufc like
i mentioned watch netflix let's get them
to go over and play games i feel like
the social aspect should be the core and
then the games obviously there's some
good games on the on the oculus quest
too but i don't feel like there's any
killer apps i don't feel like there's
anything that i could convince my friend
off how it looks to go out and buy an
oculus quest 2. i think that's something
that they really need to focus on and
they need to focus more on making their
own original titles i'm not necessarily
just getting triple a games it's on
consoles or pc and porting them over to
a vr setting to put them into oculus
quest 2 or vive whatever vr for that
matter but we're talking about the quest
to hear for instance i played resident
evil 4. it's a good experience but it's
not something that i as a resident evil
4 fan was expecting when i went into the
vr because it's not exactly one for one
that's in the actual resident evil 4.
don't get me wrong it's a crazy
experience and it's something that i
probably wasn't mentally ready to
to take on so you got to look at it from
the perspective of someone that maybe
you know they like the the concept of vr
but they've never had a game that wants
them to go and jump onto the vr but
resident evil 4 comes out and that's a
very popular game so they went out and
picked up a quest 2 to play resident
evil 4. and then they find out that the
experience they played on the ps4 on the
xbox one or on the ps5 and
xbox series x it's the same but it's not
the same at the same time and you know
sometimes you can get a little motion
sickness on depending on how you move
around because it kind of does like
these 45 degree angles every time you
move it's not like a traditional moving
system and you can put like a point and
click where you would move straight to
it now i'm not saying it's like a
horrible experience or anything i
actually think it's a fantastic
experience you actually have to like
manually reload your gun it's like on
your waist and then you have to you have
to like reach to the left to get the
first aid kit can spray things like
that's cool it's just i'm not saying
that they don't need to do stuff like
that they obviously need to reach out to
the developers and try to get more
mainstream media mainstream apps on the
oculus quest 2 or any vr for that matter
to get more of those people to actually
try the vr but i don't think it should
be the focus it should be one of those
things where you get on vr for that
killer app that they made from the
ground up for a vr experience and you
can buy resident evil 4 when you're done
with that and now i'm not saying people
didn't buy a quest 2 for resonating 4.
i'm sure there's a bunch of people but
myself particular i felt like resident
evil 4 was the least fun i had playing
the quest to it's talking about demio i
probably butchered that name but i will
put gameplay in the background and show
what i'm talking about this is the vip
this is the go facebook i'm pretty sure
facebook's the one that does oculus go
out and buy these developers give them
that money because i feel like this
experience is what really captivated me
to give the vr space more of an
opportunity i'm not a dungeons dragons
kind of person i've never been but me
playing this with my friends i saw what
i had possibly been missing out on now
i'm not saying that this is
a killer app or anything by that means
but i'm saying a few type of social
interacting games like this and you got
yourself a winner
so conclusion
i do believe vr has a future
i believe vr can actually do something
great in the future i do think that they
have a long way to go and i think the
foundation to get there isn't as long as
people think
but i do see companies such as sony
companies such as oculus they're taking
that initiative and they're making a lot
of investments into that space and i'm
looking forward to the future of vr
i wouldn't say that i'm 100 sold on vr
but i will say i'm way more sold on vr
than i was two weeks ago but anyway
that's my review on the oculus
definitely hit that like button if you
guys enjoyed the video and until next
time this is gaming addict lord addict
and definitely catch the iop the iron
lords podcast peace